good afternoon and yeah after
a shooting rampage across henderson
christopher mcdonnell now faces
20 charges and he could face more
prosecutors are considering terrorism
and hate crime enhancements mcdonald
appeared for his
court appearance today via video
conference the most serious charge
against him is one count of murder
on thanksgiving henderson police say
mcdonnell and two others shot at almost
a dozen innocent bystanders based on
statements given to police
prosecutors now believe those shootings
may have been racially motivated
at least five different scenes one of
them at the 7-eleven on lake mead
parkway and center street
where investigators say year 22-year-old
kevin mendiola jr
which was just sitting in a pickup truck
when he was murdered
the four other people shot that day are
expected to recover
and today we got to hear a little bit
from mcdonald
as he faced a judge have you hired an
attorney
on your own to represent you on this
case today sir
um can you afford to hire an attorney on
your own sir
your
the other two said to be involved in the
shooting spree are kaylee lewis and sean
mcdonald
sean is christopher's brother they were
all arrested in arizona after a shootout
with authorities there and we've learned
federal authorities are offering help
with the investigation
because of the shootings in arizona
before all of this mcdonald was already
on parole
for a violent felony case in texas
reporting from henderson hector mejia 8
news now